Joshua Ali was just speculating there on
what options may be open now to shamima
Bagan where does she go from here
I think she goes to the court of appeal
I think she tries to challenge the
decision from sayak the special
immigration appeals commission which was
handed down today I haven't seen the
full judgment yet it's not appeared on
the psych website it will obviously be
studied by her lawyers to see if there
is any opportunity of appeal any grounds
for appeal I'm sure that they will find
some arguments don't forget this case
has already been to the Supreme Court on
the question of whether
should have been allowed to travel to
London in order to give evidence to this
court in London uh in support of her
appeal and the Supreme Court overturning
earlier decisions said no she was a
security risk she couldn't be allowed to
return to London and no doubt her
lawyers will argue that that put her at
a disadvantage at the hearing last
November but no I would be pretty
confident that we will hear from her
lawyers that they will seek to challenge
this decision it's really their only
option as your other correspondents have
been explaining because I don't think
Bangladesh is going to allow her in I
don't suppose any other country is going
to offer her a passport and so really
this is her only option as I say to
challenge this decision from Mr Justice
J at the special immigration appeals
commission this morning